my talk at the table is actually a
tribute to foo fighters drummer taylor
hawkins
[Music]
i absolutely did not want this to be
true but taylor hawkins died on friday
in colombia he was just 50 years old the
rock and roll hall of famer was known
for his ferocious drum solos and a heart
of gold hawkins played with the likes of
alanis morissette before he joined the
foo fighters and stayed with the band
for more than 20 years the foo fighters
were touring in south america when
hawkins was found unresponsive in his
hotel room colombian officials say
initial tests show he had about 10 types
of substances in his system but a cause
of death has not been determined uh the
entire music world was broken up let me
just share with you some tweets from
people that we know and love slash
tweeted of no words to express all the
feelings i have about his passing mick
jagger so incredibly sad tom morello i
love your spirit and unstoppable rock
power quest love said i'm so sad about
this man and nandi bushel we know nandi
yeah the little drummer drummer
extraordinaire wrote this tribute it is
heartbreaking thank you for looking
after me thank you for being so kind and
loving
thank you for being the most awesome
drummer yeah ever thinking of dave grohl
and the rest of the the band i know that
they canceled that the south africa
south american portion of their tour and
came back to the state you know it's the
way that taylor played with such
exuberance when he's back there even if
it was a nice and easy song big me and
how in sync he was with dave dave would
turn to him at the end of a song like
big me and he would hold his guitar and
taylor would sit there and just the sink
that they had the exuberance that he
played the drums which is why it's so
heartbreaking to know that he won't be
doing that 50 is very young very young
and we'll miss him very young
you're right he will be missed